white crosses candles and flowers stand
in a growing memorial to El Paso's dead
and injured this city already reeling in
the wake of an apparent racist rampage
has suffered another body blow
unfortunately these wounds have been
devastating and major and we are deeply
saddened to be here today to have to
tell you that two patients have passed
one elderly woman ended up passing away
in the middle of the night and then
another patient patient just recently
passed away names and faces of the
victims of Saturday's shooting emerged
one was a 15 year old high school soccer
star another a woman in her 80s Jordan
and Andre are Chando were gunned down as
they shielded their infant son who
survived other survivors were coping
with trauma US Army Specialist Glendon
Oakley carried children to safety after
the shooting broke out I'm just focused
are the kids get a baby that was long
because it hurts me I lost they were
part of me
the city has adopted the slogan El Paso
strong and businesses faith leaders and
community organizers are stepping up to
help a group of funeral directors
announced they would offer arrangements
for victims including at least eight
Mexican citizens we're going to be
giving them all the services completely
free without a cost we could do
transfers to Mexico and that's going to
be completely free to them their gesture
will save families thousands of dollars
in expenses in a speech at the White
House on Monday President Trump
denounced white supremacy and racism but
many people here in El Paso say words
are not enough
we really need to repudiate this hate
speech and this demagoguery where we are
having a scapegoat on immigrants as
though there's somehow the problem
that's going
our society a community shaken to its
core but coming together in unity
against the forces of hate Rob Reynolds
al-jazeera El Paso